what is it about eddie in this
relationship that just kind of i don't
know it seems like it completes you
it definitely does i'm i feel very
excited every day that i get to date him
it seems like you found your guy i think
so
you just did a musical west side story
and you could have done a romantic movie
you could do comedies but you apparently
were drawn to the really dark subject
matter of the fallout you don't even
need to wear makeup
sorry what
i just said you don't even need to wear
makeup
all right
what was it that you were like i need to
go in this direction i've always been
really drawn to the heavy rolls just
because they have so much depth to them
and especially something like this
uh kind of like this sort of topic is so
important and needs to be talked about
there was a lot of scenes where i was a
little nervous going into just because i
am newer to acting and i was just you
know doubting myself am i capable of
bringing this story to life and megan
made it the most easy safe environment
to walk into every day she's just a
genius she's literally changed my life
in so many ways so i really love her
what scene comes to mind which one were
you like how the heck am i gonna do this
jenna and i had to do some scenes where
we were under the influence i very much
was like i have to nail this and i have
to make it as accurate as possible were
you googling or youtube watching you
know what does someone do when they're
rolling joints or what does someone do
when they're stumbling around drunk
totally had to watch a lot of a lot of
videos get a lot of uh kind of tips from
a lot of people on set
um obviously you know i was drinking
like cranberry juice or whatever it was
but
i really had a blast uh going there with
those scenes amazing i can tell you
really went for it and it definitely
paid off um i'm curious you know your
inner circle we know your mom we know
your sister we know your boyfriend
who has had the most intense reaction to
the film and seeing this side of you
oh i mean they all have in a lot of ways
i think
first of all my mom cries with
everything i do uh and so does my sister
my sister was very emotional watching it
and so was actually my boyfriend he i
watched it with him and he cried
watching it i really hit home for him in
a way and i i very much um
am so grateful that they responded well
to the movie just because their approval
means a lot to me i watched you on the
tonight show the other night you were so
wonderful so articulate but what really
got me was your boyfriend eddie
benjamin's beautiful post you know he's
just in awe of your talent at least
that's what i got from his caption and
as his career is skyrocketing and your
career is skyrocketing what does it mean
to have one another to support each
other during these really exciting times
oh my gosh it is the best case scenario
i'm so grateful to i always was like
i'll never date someone that's in the
industry just because i don't know it's
intense but
we very much are
we inspired well he definitely inspires
me every day um and he says that about
me which i'm like hopefully we feed off
of each other so much and i think it's
so cool that we push each other every
day and he's also
like completely diving into this world
and i've been in it for a second so it's
cool that we can like give each other
advice um and yeah he's just been so
supportive and i i'm i'm just like his
biggest fan i can't wait for people to
hear his music because it's just like
absolutely insane i mean listen between
the harper's bizarre cover and then you
be
music video there just seems something
and even the way you're talking right
now you're you're lighting up i mean
what is it about eddie in this
relationship that just kind of i don't
know it seems like it completes you
it definitely does i'm i feel very
excited every day that i get to date him
we have such a good time together and we
were best friends for a really long time
before we dated so
it's like i'm just hanging out with my
best friend every day it's really fun
it's it's honestly the best i love it
yeah it seems like you found your guy
i think so
i saw in fallon you said you're excited
to join him on the road are you going to
be dancing on stage oh definitely not
not oh okay is his thing i'm just going
to sit from afar and watch and cheer him
on uh no i
he he doesn't need anyone backing him up
he's perfect on his own definitely okay
so you'll be there cheering posters in
the audience all that good stuff crying
just being like a proud girlfriend yeah
definitely
[Music]
it's the shoulders you can't do it
without the shoulders oh yeah
i love how megan in your movie the
fallout she very beautifully takes these
pop culture references and injects them
into the script and one of my favorite
things was seeing jenna's on-screen
younger sister she does a little
tick-tock dancing in the movie
and i have a bone to pick with you
maddie i love following you on tick-tock
but you don't post nearly enough i want
more i want more of your fun videos
where does your relationship with like
tik tok and social media stand today
yeah i it took me a very long time as
people know to get on the app in general
um and then i made a few tick tocks and
it was fun and then i got kind of like
scared i was like oh no i don't know if
i'm like funny and i just got in my head
so i was like
i'm just gonna like have the app and i i
go on it like every day and i have so
many drafts and so many like funny
videos but
i'm just like ah i just don't it's not
right it's not right so maybe one day
i'll start posting again but i love
watching videos on tick tock because it
honestly like is the one social media
platform that is positive for me and i
don't feel like i'm comparing myself
like it's really fun we love seeing you
it doesn't have to be perfect if you're
doing makeup or dancing
truly i just i love watching it and i
have to know you said that you're you're
on tick tock constantly have you seen
this boss ladies dance challenge that's
making the rounds yes i've seen it
everywhere it's hilarious put your hands
up in the air put your hands up in the
air put your hands up in the air put
your hands up
i love that that's coming back up again
because that was such a fun dance and
it's so funny like seeing my sister and
nia and someone
it's hilarious all right can we count on
you to uh to give it a go i'm the last
one i haven't done it yet but i'm just
like too scared to post a video so i
don't know if it'll ever come but i
definitely know what's going on i'm i'm
all in
thanks to tick-tock and like social
media what do you make of that chapter
of your life which was a decade ago
now having this resurgence with younger
audiences who are learning about dance
moms and your past and how you got your
start i mean how does that make you feel
it's really cool it's it's like a full
circle moment and i'm i'm really like i
i don't know if people really
see this from me but i'm so grateful for
the show because it got me to where i am
today and it's helped me you know with
so many opportunities and i'm so
grateful for that and to see like
girls being like if you didn't know this
dance when you were younger then like
where were you and i'm like i didn't
know that many people even like learned
the boss ladies dance and
it's it's honestly it's the cutest thing
ever it warms my heart it's it's really
fun
[Music]
you're just crushing it across the board
you're you're acting and you've got your
incredible podcast with your sister what
is the next chapter of maddie ziegler
look like i'm fully diving into acting i
look i love it so so so much obviously i
i would love to do like maybe a fashion
collab in the future you know work with
a really cool designer i might have
something fun
coming back
having to do with some glam so you know
we'll see
is there a bucket list
acting moment that you've got in your
brain whether it's winning an oscar or
working with a specific actor actress or
director totally i mean it would be
insane to even be nominated for an award
uh in terms of like maybe the oscars i
i'm not even gonna like i'm just gonna
put into the universe i'm gonna manifest
that i know that one day it could
probably happen if i work hard enough um
you know even if it doesn't i'm just so
grateful and also like i got to work
with steven spielberg which is like
bucket list like how did that happen i'm
just
like i don't understand why i deserve
this because i'm just like there's so
many cool people and i i'm just so cool
stop saying that you're so talented and
i know that you've just like scratched
the tip of the iceberg
who's next give me like an actor and an
actress that you're like i will be in a
movie with these people in 2023. oh my
gosh oh i mean i'm obsessed with
jennifer anson i love reese witherspoon
um i love jennifer lawrence there's so
many insane like female actresses that i
would love to work with um
they're so amazing and they inspire me
so much so that would be awesome
[Music]
you